The joe rogan experience.
Do you think the people create that?
I mean,
that's like the big a,
the big hippy,
new age.
A argument about lives that you create
these possibilities in life,
that you,
you're responsible for all these
different events that are happening too.
They're not random events.
These are events that are sort of
created by your own intentions.
Yes.
Do you feel that sometimes,
absolutely.
One thing I learned was that till you
take responsibility,
you ain't gonna move forward.
There's mother fuckers that get off the
stage,
bro.
Audio sucks the sound that I watched a
guy eat the pie.
Fuck ate shit.
Fucking bombed.
Yeah.
And that's it.
And everything else.
And until you come through that you
can't really,
and that was big for me that I believe
that,
you know,
and listen,
I go to bed now,
I go home,
I put my feet up,
I watch the news and I go to bed like
nothing.
You know,
20 years ago I didn't go to bed late.
I had to shut my window a certain way
and close my door,
shut away,
and I couldn't leave the light on at
night because I owed money to a drug
dealer like rob somebody.
I created all those scenarios.
I didn't,
I didn't make that kidnapping up.
I went there with a gun.
I knew that was doing,
but it's funny that quick,
the turnaround was between like 99 you
know,
like it's,
it all just sort of stopped and also
luggage and it kept stopping.
You know,
it kept stopping and kept getting
better.
What you're telling me is that I never
did blog at after 2006 that's,
you're trying to tell me who me.
That's you're trying to tell me to say
the weirdest way to phrase that
sentence.
I'm saying that I haven't done Boston
show.
One day I went home one day I went home
because even with a chick,
so one day I went home and just stopped
doing book.
That's it.
You're trying to tell me you've never
done that again.
That's what I'm saying.
I'm saying about being a criminal.
No,
no,
no.
I'm busting your balls.
I can't believe what I'm fucking telling
you.
That's nice.
2006 one day I went home.
Brian,
one day I went home and just stopped
doing cocaine though.
Rehab,
no hug.
I didn't call nobody.
I didn't piss my ear.
I didn't give my life to our game.
There was none of that shit.
He'll,
okay,
whatever the fuck that shit is,
it can never go.
It was nothing.
Whatever the photo book,
game,
Whatever Shit.
So my point is that what happened was I
dropped.
I kept dropping the pain that I had and
that luggage that I had,
I forced it out.
I just didn't fucking stop doing drugs.
I overcame whatever was making me do
those fucking drugs.
Society wasn't making me do drugs.
Obama care.
How funny is that?
They found heroin in the Bronx with
obamacare envelope.
Austin,
Boston man hysteric instead obamacare on
it was on heroin.
Obamacare,
like people would just let that in.
Everything we create everything in a lot
of wings.
This random things can happen as well.
I broke this.
Sometimes people wake up on the wrong
side of the fucking bed.
They come at you and you got to stand
your fucking ground and you got to say
no bitch.
And people get their feelings hurt.
Yes,
but no,
I created a lot of the shit that
happened in my life.
There's no fuck
what?
Sink into what you are right now.
Just be that thing.
Stop resisting exactly where you are
right now is perfect.
And that's a hard truth to grasp because
you think right away you think.
Yeah.
What about fucking Jeffrey Dahmer?
Is he perfect?
Well,
what about the leopard when you're
seeing a leopard rip apart a creature?
Is that thing per,
is that a perfect,
don't think the Leopard fucks them and
kills him.
But do you know what ducks do?
Ducks or necrophilia acts.
Are they fucking evil creatures?
Yes,
I think they are.
Yeah,
they are made that Phil Robertson Guy,
very famous person,
and he invented a call for them and now
poor gay people have to hear that a
man's anus is not as good as a woman's
vagina.
Can you imagine if you made the choice
for a man's anus and you hear this
fucking big bearded fashion Easter with
his Camo on a Bandana is absolute
fashiony so weird.
I never thought of that.
Big bearded Christian Bible slinging
Fashionista.
And uh,
he tells you that your choice was
incorrect and in fact the woman's vagina
is the better choice.
The man's anus.
I mean,
come on guys.
But as you say that,
if you haven't experienced it,
maybe,
yeah,
I think he has a,
again,
the balance theory,
I think he's so outspoken on that issue.
Like most of these homophobes are
because they're home jerking off to gay
porn,
you know,
otherwise you just don't give a shit.
It's a closing actually matter.
Right?
It doesn't come up in a gq interview.
It's a duck thing,
right?
It's like Duh,
ready?
Like if you really care if people are
gay,
Duh,
you really care.
The two guys love each other and that
you are you against love.
You only like love if it's a man and a
woman.
Like what the fuck man?
Really,
it's done.
It is talking about men's anuses in Gq.
Sorry,
Glen,
maybe you've got some issues to think
about.
What shouldn't we just be talking about
ducks,
ducks and scene isn't that your whole
show was he should ducks all the time,
right?
That's your thing.
Like let's just talk about murdering
ducks.
Yeah.
Why you got to talk about men's
ragging.
This in the blood sack sucks penises
and that is why that,
you know,
the duck dynasty guy or any of these
Weirdos who are um,
um,
you were just ultimately just angry
people.
That's why they seem so fucking crazy
war.
They play angry people on TV.
Right?
Cause I think a lot of these people
aren't even,
you know,
like dynasty guy.
The Duck Dynasty guy has been given
speeches like that for years that these
biblical retreats and stuff,
he's been doing that for this video.
So this is real stick.
He's not fire and brimstone God fearing
Christian man who was living on the
wrong side of the law and Jesus at one
point in time and then turned it all
around and wants to let everybody know
about the evils of sin.
He's an old dummy.
That's what he is.
He's an old dominant lobe name for him.
He's an old dummy to probably just one
time sucked a dick and liked it way too
much or someone sucked his and it's his
favorite moment.
He looks back on his childhood and he's
turned it into,
you know,
stay rear.
I bet he was going to happen.
We were in that duck blind.
They're all liquored up on moonshine and
coats and ducks.
I bet.
Right when he came into like some guy's
mouth years ago,
out in the out in the fucking house
swaps,
he saw to call it a duck blind combined
pleasure and shame mixed inside of me.
He's like,
I'm just going to kill ducks from now on
and never think about this dog.
She didn't see shit.
Your Mother didn't see shit.
Your father didn't see shit.
Nobody saw shit.
I'm good to few magic.
That's really what it was.
All it was just a duck song.
Get his dick sucked by a guy and he's
like,
fuck that.
It didn't happen.
Didn't happen.
He did kill ducks.
I think that's something like that
happen,
man.
It's something like that happen.